I want to thank you so much the 97
people who have already purchased their
jar of farts 90 Day Fiance star
Stephanie matto says she made thousands
of dollars by selling drum roll please
jars of her farts I made 45 000 in one
week selling my jars of farts the
reality star is going viral after
explaining the unusual way she makes
money on social media posting these
snaps posing with some of her
merchandise explaining in the caption
quote due to popular demand I have
finally decided to start selling my
Jarred farts Stephanie adds that she's
quote super excited to give the people
what they want I'm super excited it's
crazy this feels so surreal the cost for
one jar of the 31 year old's gas one
thousand dollars but the first 100
orders got their farts 50 off and
according to Steph she made more than
forty five thousand dollars in a single
week I've been getting a lot of
questions such as how long do the farts
last did I really Fart 97 times in two
days who buys my farts and why and what
are some of my tips
tricks
Stephanie is documenting the journey
along the way answering everything her
fans want to know so the first question
I get asked a lot is how long do the
farts last and the smell is most
prominent for the first two days but as
I like to say one with makes memories
that last a lifetime
now why do people buy my farts in a jar
I honestly think it's because
I have a really good personality
and also because I'm hot she also walks
her followers through a day in her life
you know selling her toots so I like to
get things roll in with some beans a
protein muffin sometimes even a yogurt
less sugar is better some hard-boiled
eggs and today I decided I was gonna
make myself a protein shake with some
yogurt added to it and oh I was feeling
it for sure while I wait for those parts
to develop I like to read I'm very smart
love to read and then after I'm ready to
go I go ahead and you know do my work do
my job I don't need to show you that
guys Stephanie even goes the extra mile
adding a little flower petal to each jar
I feel like they attach the scent and
make it last longer and when I'm finally
finished with my jar I like to leave a
personalized note as for the haters
Stephanie seems unfazed posting this
clip noting that she's made over one
hundred thousand dollars has a beautiful
home and several cars
your break but I think you're being
exploited oh yeah
I don't mind as long as I get paid for
it but this isn't the first time
Stephanie has broken new ground I
probably like her way more than she
likes me right now back in 2020 she sat
down with E.T shortly after she made
history as part of the first ever
same-sex couple to be featured on 90 Day
Fiance with her then girlfriend Erica I
feel like there's a lot of pressure you
know you don't want to let down anybody
you don't want to let down the LGBT
community and
a part of me wants to be like great
representation for this community but
also I think
we all just need to realize we're just
like any other couple we're gonna have
just you know similar problems to all
the other couples on the show and this
is a huge moment coming out for me
because I've you know just recently come
out and you came out on the show yep I'm
in love with somebody and that somebody
is a girl it was uh it was very scary
and it was kind of like ripping off a
Band-Aid that's been there for a very
long time and I'm always crazy and doing
wild spontaneous things I do put a lot
of my life out there online but this was
a part of me that I've kept kind of
private and so now I'm just putting it
all out there and a few months later ET
spoke with Erica who weighed in on their
relationship highs and lows and the
skepticism over Stephanie coming out as
bisexual on the show honestly I can only
speak from my experience and who I am
sexuality is a very very personal thing
and sometimes it takes like exploring
yourself
um to be able to figure that out you
know and it sucks that at some points I
felt like the figuring out of things was
at my expense
um but I don't I'm not gonna sit here
and say that she is something or she
isn't because that's her own personal
journey I want to make other people feel
less alone and I want other people to
feel understood because for such a long
time I felt really misunderstood and you
know there's a lot of stigma in the LGBT
community but there's also a lot of
stigma for bisexuals it's not taken
seriously even within the LGBT community
it's like oh you know like why can't you
just choose why don't you just decide
are you into men are you into women but
I'm really proud and happy that we are
going to be the first couple that is
going to be kind of unveiling all these
issues and
showing the world what it's really like